So zooming out a little bit from the player related stuff,
there's a set of classes that we should talk about that are
regarded under what is strictly called the Unreal gameplay
framework that apply more to the world than a specific player
that we should just talk about a little bit.
So those are the game mode, the game state,
and the game instance.
Starting with the game mode, as the name might imply,
this is kind of the rules of the game,
the kind of more static data about the game.
There might be things like, how many players are there?
How many players are allowed to join this game?
Where might those players spawn?
How many points do you need to win the game?
And quite importantly, for both online and single player
games, the game mode also specifies the default classes
that we're going to spawn for each of these things.
So it specifies your default player classes.
It specifies the player control class
to spawn for each player.
Moving on from that, we have the game state.
If you think about this as the real time state of the game,
in the context of a networked game,
the game mode is going to be server only.
It's going to be authoritative.
But the game state is actually a replicated actor.
So the game state is the shared real time
state of that game between both the server and the client.
So if we took capture the flag game as an example,
the game mode would specify maybe how many points
you need to score.
But the actual current score would be something
we store in the game state.
So that can be replicated across all the clients
so everyone has an up to date idea of what
the current score is.
The third class that we need to talk about is the game
instance.
And this is for storing our persistent data
throughout an entire gameplay session.
Whilst the game mode and the game state
are destroyed and respawned every time we transition level,
obviously we would want our score to reset to zero, right?
And when we're going from one level to a different level,
maybe we've gone from the shooter level
to the car driving game mode.
So we have different default pawns and things like that.
Whereas we want that stuff to kind of get,
we intentionally want it to be torn down and rebuilt,
the game instance is where we're
going to store things that persist between those levels.
So say, for example, we start the game
and client one chooses to be on team red.
We want some way to store data that is going
to persist between two levels, right?
They should still be on team red when they go into level two.
And therefore, that's something that we
might do in the game instance.
So just as a kind of visual demonstration,
this same thing happening.
We have a kind of imagining a multiplayer game set up here.
We have level one.
The game mode, again, only on our server
because it's authoritative.
The rules of the game are defined there.
And the clients don't need to worry too much about them.
The game state exists on the server
and is replicated to our clients.
But both our client and our server
have their own instances.
And as we go from level one to level two,
the server game instance remains
and the client instance remains.
They don't communicate with each other,
but they are persistent between levels.
And again, here you can see that when we start level two,
we get a second game mode and we get a second game
state because the game mode, the game state
may have changed.
Talking a little bit more about how we actually specify
that game mode, there's a couple of different ways
we could do this.
We can go into the default engine any in our configs
and specify our game mode here.
So when you want to set the kind of default game
mode for your game, you can do that here
through the any files.
Most of the time when you have an any file
and it's got fields you can edit,
you can edit it in a kind of more visually easy
to pass kind of way inside the engine
through the project settings.
So in the project settings maps and mode section,
there's a default game mode there.
But the other thing you can do is specify a different game
mode per level.
Like we said, maybe in one level
you're running around in first person shooter mode
and maybe for another level you're driving cars.
So that's something you can actually override in the world
settings of each level.
Beyond worrying about just the kind of more static data
present in game mode, there is a bit of functionality
that is worth being concerned about.
The other thing to mention is that when
we're making a game mode, when we're
making a class that inherits from game mode,
there's actually two points we can branch from.
There's the game mode base class, which as the name kind
of would imply is the base class for game mode.
And then there is a class called game mode, which
inherits from game mode base.
Game mode essentially implements some additional multiplayer
specific functionality on top of game mode base.
So if you're making a single player standalone game,
it's quite likely you'll want your game mode
classes to inherit from game mode base, not the game mode
class.
So there's a set of virtual functions
available to both of these that are just
worth talking a little bit about.
There is a lot more than these,
but these are just some kind of really common ones
that you would want to utilize.
In it game is called really, really early in the game
flow, and it's kind of like our initial kickoff point.
It's called before we even initialized components.
And it's essentially a point where
we initialize any just super early data
that we need to be a certain way before anything else begins.
Then kind of from that point onwards,
we're going to talk about things that are fired
specifically on a per player basis.
So first we have pre-login.
This is essentially responsible for possibly rejecting
a player's connection.
So this is before that player actually exists in that game.
It's kind of worth mentioning that there's
kind of a non-trivial amount of time,
or possibly non-trivial amount of time,
between the pre-login functionality
and the actual login function for that player,
especially if that player has a lot of content they need
to download.
There might be quite a long time between those two things.
Post-login is the point at which we have succeeded
logging in.
Nothing's gone wrong with our download process.
Our player has been accepted.
So this is the first point where we can actually say, yes,
this player is in this game.
They'll have a player controller at this point.
So this might be the point where
you display some kind of UI to say, hey,
this person has joined the game.
Next, we go on to handling starting a new player.
So once that player has started the game,
we need to go through this process of injecting them
into the actual game mode.
And that's where handleStartNewPlayer comes in.
At this point, you might be doing something like assigning
them a team to be on.
And there might be certain data that extrapolates from that.
And then handleStartingPlayer would then
call eventually restartPlayer.
But obviously, as the name implies,
restartPlayer is also called several times
if your character dies.
So restartPlayer gets called in with your player controller.
And it's the response of the ability of restartPlayer
to perform a bunch of functionality
about choosing a pawn for that player
and spawning it in that place.
That will eventually then call spawnDefaultPawn at transform.
By default, that's just going to default back
to what the game mode specifies as a default pawn.
But this is passed in with the player controller.
So if for some reason, say for example,
that player chose a character before they entered this level,
you could specify specifically for this player controller
spawning this character rather than the game mode's
default pawn.
And then after all of that, those last two functions
are going to be called multiple times
as that player possibly dies and gets respawned.
But finally, when that player chooses to leave,
when they either leave or the player is destroyed,
onLogout is called.
And this might be the point at which
you want to display to other players
that player has left the game.
Then that's kind of shared functionality
between the two of them.
Game mode specifically, like we said,
it's kind of more specifically geared to multiplayer games.
Hypothetically, any of those things might be useful
even in a single player game,
because your player might join that map for the first time
and you still want to edit some of this functionality.
Game mode specifically,
the kind of more multiplayer centric one,
has access to this concept of match states.
And you'll see that game mode itself
overrides some of these functions.
So say, for example, handleStartingNewPlayer,
where game mode essentially just asks a couple of questions
about whether or not we should be spawning
that player's pawn in.
One of the things game mode will check against
is whether or not we're waiting to start.
Waiting to start might be an example
of our classic waiting for more players screen.
So the game is technically starting,
but there's just not enough players
to start this game running.
So game mode has an additional check
for are we in waiting to start?
If so, then don't spawn like their default pawn,
maybe spawn a spectator spawn or something like that.
As we mentioned,
there's a couple of different states available to us.
We're entering the map, meaning things are starting up.
Waiting to start, so when we're waiting for other players.
In progress, as you expected, the game is ongoing.
Waiting post match is people might be reviewing
their scores, might be voting on the next map to go to,
and leaving map is when we're transitioning
into the next level.
Game state is, as we already mentioned a little bit,
is really for our game's runtime, real-time data.
So it doesn't have so much in the way of functionality.
It's not such a heavy class
in terms of things we would need to override.
It's really just a place we should feel quite comfortable
to put any data that we want to be,
that is broadly game-wide,
that we want to be communicated to each of the players.
It's worth mentioning though, specifically,
that this is not on a per player basis.
So this is the kind of global data
for all the players to see.
If we're worrying about data on a per player basis,
that's handled somewhere else, which is the player state,
which we'll get onto next.
So we mentioned very briefly about player-specific data.
This isn't one of those classes that we mentioned before,
but just because we're talking about replicating data
across the server, it's worth touching briefly
on the player state.
Much like the game state, the player state is intended
for holding the, hence the name, state of our player.
If we kind of look at an example setup here,
we've got the server for our game.
That server would have a player controller for player one
and a player controller for player two.
It would also have state for each of those players.
Now, whilst the server kind of contains all of this stuff,
our clients would actually see
a slightly restricted view,
where each client sees their own player controller.
They don't see every other player's player controller.
That's what player state is for.
So a little bit like game mode to game state,
player state is the same thing in reflection to,
oh my God, I've lost the flow there.
So whereas the game state is for the game-wide state
that is gonna be shared information across all players,
for player-specific information,
that's where it would come to the player state.
If we kind of just take an example kind of setup here,
we have the server.
For each client connected to the server,
the server is gonna spawn in a player controller
and a player state.
If we look at each of these clients, however,
a client sees their own player controller,
but they don't see other client's player controller.
So client one doesn't see client two's player controller,
client two doesn't see player one's player controller.
So for any information that is shared between the players,
if I as a player need to see information
about another player,
that's something that should be put on the player state.
Every client will have all of the other client's
replicated information done through the player state.
That might, very much like the player controller,
this information persists beyond pawns.
So if you think about it,
whereas the pawn might have something like health,
something like that player's score
or the last location that player spawned at
or their combo bonus or something like that,
any information that is kind of like abstracted
from the pawn specifically,
but other clients would need to see
that's going to be on your player state.
Obviously it's replicated,
so therefore it supports all your typical RPCs.
And very much like the game state,
your player state is specified by your game mode.
So if we can just see,
you can see you specify in your game mode,
which player state class to use for this level
or for your game in general.
So in our last presentation,
we talked a little bit about the flow
that an actor goes through as it gets spawned in.
And we saw that that's different
depending on if you're playing an editor,
if that actor has been spawned in
when the level was created
or when you spawned it in at runtime,
it's somewhat similar for the engine.
And that's because obviously there's two ways
we can come into the engine.
We can come into it through the editor
and we can come in through a standalone game
that we've packaged.
For the most part, these are relatively similar,
but there's a few key things to kind of bear in mind.
Firstly, when we're in editor,
our engine has started at the point
we started our editor.
So there's this kind of period of time
before we hit our play and editor button
where the engine will kind of exist,
but we don't yet have a game instance.
On the other side, when we've made a packaged game,
game instance actually exists
before our engine gets started.
That's kind of a key discrepancy.
There's also some slightly different functions are called.
We have initialized PIE
when we're calling the play and editor,
whereas when we're doing a packaged game,
we get game instance initialized standalone.
But ultimately it all funnels together
into this word begin play.
Again, just worth explaining here
that this kind of really highlights
the fundamental nature of the game instance,
that this is really created
right at the beginning of the engine,
right when our XE first starts up.
So before anything to do with a world exists as a concept,
we already have our game instance.
Next, once we're actually within a world,
that's where our world itself begins play.
And then one of the first things we'll do
is create our game mode.
And from there on, we have the game mode flow.
So our game mode start play
and then our game mode start match.
It's only after that,
that we begin to spawn other actors and begin the game.
So this really can demonstrate the primacy of the game mode
as a really fundamental gameplay class.
You can trust that the game mode
is gonna have its start behavior, its start logic,
and therefore its begin play
called before any of the classes.
So even at a purely blueprint level
where you might not be getting into really fundamentals
of all the engine flow,
you can kind of trust that
if you want to inject some logic
that you can trust is going to be called
before player controllers,
before pawns get spawned or anything like this,
put that within the game mode,
because that's gonna be one of the first things
that come within your runtime level.